so how has just for last montreal been
treating you so far
it's been good it's been good it's good
to be back man um i started coming to
this festival and performing uh in 2015
and it's it's like a thing that's annual
i i i love coming here seeing all my
friends that that were all too busy to
kind of see each other in any other way
and then um i bought these t-shirts in
the mall um these really soft ass
t-shirts
they're only in canada and so on
yeah it's good
why am i like this tour why is this such
a fun show for you to perform here um
the one i like this story is because
it's gonna be it's my special and i'm
shooting that in august and um it's
really fun just to put the work up so
that like
your peers can see you know what i mean
um like uh you know industry obviously
the people who are paying you to do this
special can
see it and and no they don't have to
pull out their money um
reassurance yeah
but i talk about my mental health
journey in it and it's the first time i
really get vulnerable about that for
real so and uh so that's what's made it
really fun and kind of scary
i was gonna say how's that going then if
that's kind of the first time that
you've been this vulnerable scary's a
good word how like do you feel drained
after you do it how does it go i feel
energized and drained yeah i feel
energized and naked you know what i mean
yeah just but like from the inside does
that make sense yes yeah i'm naked on
the inside
it feels very deep
um who have you been excited to run into
because obviously at these festivals you
have the best of the best when it comes
to comedians who has it been nice to
kind of see and reconnect with um so
many people but
it was really great to be here with
langston kerman and sam j they are my
best friends in comedy and in life and
we lost our friend jack knight and
and we met here so seven years ago
uh or eight years ago i guess and um
yeah so it all started here and we were
we talked like every day
since since then so coming back here was
a little hard but
bittersweet right yeah yeah cathartic
when we got to the show and we roasted
them and it was great oh i love that
what's your favorite thing about working
with jack
man everything man
was a maniac uh he's a brilliant he's a
brilliant dude he was he was brilliant
he always was tapped in trying to learn
more trying to inspire you and like
learn more live life so he can create
better
he's like a hard ass worker man like
work ethic on another level
um and just
funny
just a very funny funny dude man
very kind yeah i love hearing that uh so
lauren michaels has said that he will be
committed to snl
until its 50th anniversary keenan
thompson just came out he's like oh
maybe it's not a bad idea to end snl
after its 50th season what do you feel
about that
um
i don't think i get paid enough to care
that's such a great idea
it's like you know what i'm saying i
guess y'all that's your house you know i
i mean you know my contract gonna be up
around that time yeah so um
it'll be cool to see the 50th you know
uh
and
i think that lauren should do whatever
he wants to do for himself you know what
i mean he's he's uh he's he's changed a
lot of lives over a lot of you know a
long period of time and so he's ready to
tap you know i'm saying it'd be
interesting to see him try to stop
working that would be interesting to see
he's a workaholic
you deserve it but i don't know if
you're gonna sit down but um
but yeah i mean i don't know i guess all
things come to an end or or drastic
change at some point but i've never
really thought about it because i
haven't been there as long as they have
yeah
but um i know i'll be gone i don't know
when yeah i'm not gonna say because i'm
gonna keep y'all on your toes oh i like
that teasing that's nice
i see how much have you grown since
being on that snl
um height wise not much but
creatively uh a lot you know it
sharpened a lot of skills a lot of
things that i didn't really like um
focus on doing yeah um
i i found like new things i'm good at
you know and it's just it's just
that place is um the hardest place to
work but it's the most rewarding mm-hmm
because you go to other sets and
nothing's harder than that so you're
just like you just feel like
this is going to be a nerdy reference
but like superman when he leaves his
planet and comes to earth he has
superpowers because he's like oh we
strong i'm from you know what i mean
like that's how it feels when you go
like to do other jobs that aren't snl
it's like just feels like you can do 50
things you know i mean it's a it's once
you go do other stuff you come back to
the show like okay yeah this is for it
yeah i liked it well i feel like this is
a great way to end this interview i
don't want to touch a jewelry but that
necklace right here that's beautiful
thank you very much this is my uh wine i
like this shane it's everything every
charm it's not done there's gonna be
four more on here but every piece uh
describes something that made me who i
am so i didn't know that yeah well you
were gorgeous
i know i feel like i should have known
that though i should have done my
research oh man journalism is going down
the toilet
i'm sorry it's my fault
you were so fun to interview your last
interview of the whole weekend and this
was worth it that was the best this is
the best and i i have not i've only said
that to another person
who was it oh who was it ali
ali colbert oh well ally is awesome
thanks so much oh thank you very much i
appreciate
you